now as you can tell box2d is a fantastic
library and the best part is this
actually free to use and we can go
downloaded off the internet and put it
in their game the author's only ask one
thing though in their licensing is that
you give them credit for using their
work now back to GD c 2011 a very
popular mobile game developer was
actually using box to the in their game
but actually forgot to credit the box2d
authors this actually came to a head at
GDC when the very popular game makers
were actually on stage during a panel
some lonely representative actually
stood up in the audience and ask them a
question from the crowd asking them what
physics engine are you using to which
they responded box2d the individual then
said hey did you know the licensing
requires you to give attribution to them
they said didn't know that he said cool
my name is Aaron kado I wrote the
library would you be willing to give me
credit of course the person said let's
talk afterwards the point is this all
that open source software out there
comes with some license so before you
actually go grab it make sure that you
read through their licensing terms very
very carefully and that you're abiding
by their usage in the proper legal way
otherwise you might get an angry Aaron
Coto showing up at your next GDC talk